damn it Boyle you left the fridge open
the door couldn't shut because of your
empty pizza box pizza please this is a
butternut squash and truffle butter
flatbread everything's spoiled my lunch
is ruined
my chicken my potatoes my pasta
meatballs
Pam
my yogurt oh it's a lot of yogurt I love
yogurt so this is your lunch for like
the month I need to eat 10 000 calories
a day to maintain muscle mass my wife
made me all of this before she left town
with the kids that was everything in my
fridge
Scully hey Sarge I know you got a secret
stash of food hidden somewhere oh no
where is it no I don't is it in your
pockets oh come on I'm gonna shake it
out of your pockets turn around charge
go live Scully oh wow this is fun
release you're sweet I'm not hungover
Hitchcock I got a tension headache I got
the lieutenants exam tonight I'm stress
eating like crazy I had 10 hard-boiled
egg yolks this morning all right gang
diet day four how's everyone holding up
honestly I'm going to last forever you
hear that [ __ ] I'm Gonna Last Forever
I'm doing great this morning the
homeless guy on my stoop said my skin
looked dope what's going on why do you
all have matching bags we're doing a
diet together my wife found it she heard
about it at mommy and me graphic design
wait it might have been toddler karate
she takes our little ladies to so many
classes I can't keep it straight
childhood is truly a Time of Wonder this
diet is very scientific sir all the
meals are pre-planned and delivered to
your doorstep this is our breakfast an
orange wedge three cashew nuts and a
solitary grape it's actually more than
you realize sometimes I can't even
finish all the grape well this seems
unnecessary to me you're all in perfect
shape you can always be healthier sir
and I like the challenge plus it's good
team building we're going to get through
this together hey guys Pro tip lick the
baggie there's food molecules in there
[Music]
hey Terry you get my email
about how I was coming down here no I
haven't checked my phone ah
no need I just wanted to make sure
you're here you know you know how I like
to have a weight mate really I have
never seen you in the gym what I
basically live here I'm a regular Jim
Dandy besides I got to get into shape
for all the godfathering I'm gonna do I
mean how am I going to throw our baby up
into the air with these noodle arms good
point so take me through your workout
man rip me up you know let's rip it out
time to rip it down those aren't gym
times and I don't think you can handle
my workout oh wow sounds like a
challenge to me come on
I gotcha ready yep
come on push it
[ __ ] yeah five
oh man this is almost too easy are you
crying no that's eyeball sweat all right
let's wrap this up I gotta call Sharon
and get back to work no no no hey I
thought you said this was gonna be a
challenge huh it's been a cakewalk so
far
oh you want me to make this harder yes
that is what I want more harder exercise
look Sarge I burned 200 calories that's
your heart rate yeah that checks out
come on take 10 more minutes
foreign
[Music]
my arms don't seem to be responding to
my brain anymore
come on man use your muscles
where's my muscles oh great why didn't I
think of that great advice Terry you
know what it's a pull-up there's not
much to coach here
okay how is you doing that helping me
good job can you do it without screaming
pra Bob Lee
6203
6204. I am so glad I lost this bet I
never find time for things I enjoy this
is so unsatisfying you're not even
sweating it's too easy get on my back
Jake
what's going on my doctor said I should
be more active but my squash Club
recently transitioned to racquetball
since I'm not a dope smoking hooligan I
decided to quit boy let's teach me yoga
Genevieve got me into it you can't
believe how many different ways I can
wrap my legs around her six Captain if
you wanted to be healthier why not come
to me I'm ripped as hell Sarge health is
about flexibility and peace of mind and
Bone strength not building vanity
muscles vanity muscles I use all of
these really even the large neck ones
they help me sleep up right on airplanes
well there's no reason to be defensive
just because you don't have the bone
strength of a yogi we all have our thing
you're a musler I'm a boner
Terry can do yoga Terry is a yoga Beast
watch give me a yoga to do uh well we're
in warrior pose now but I suppose for
you we can start in child's pose Harry
is not a child Siri is a warrior
that didn't sound good are you okay
Jeffords
I'm fine
me I'm going to walk out of here
normally using my trademark Tiny Steps
okay
oh
is it cool if I just stare at your
croissants for a little while Sarge you
need to stop this diet Amy and I folded
you one it's not a competition we were
on the same team until you deserted me
for team eating food
was that a good burn I'm too hungry to
tell it was a great burn sir now please
eat you look weak I'm fine I am stronger
than ever watch this
see I'm fine
what is happening just a tummy gurgle
damn messed up my system
oh no
[Music]
go back inside are you talking to us or
the fart Charles why did you let Terry
choose boxing he didn't I picked it but
you'll die don't worry about it boxing's
in my blood my nana boil box in the Navy
I am sure she did but and hear me out
but if you're not as strong as your nana
Boyle I can handle myself she taught me
her signature punch the strawberry
basket that does not reassure me
there big guy you sure you're feeling
okay about
ending Charles's life yep my girls are
gonna see this movie right well before
you commit manslaughter I do feel
compelled to tell you that the movie
only has a 38 on Rotten Tomatoes Jake
stop yapping and let them fight I want
to see the big guy pop the little guy's
head off yeah start the fight I want to
pop that little guy's head off you're
clearly the little guy I did one Jake
all right
I guess this is happening touch gloves
Charles it's been very nice being your
friend Terry I'll visit you in prison
and
fight strawberry basket
you mess with Grandma you're gonna get
the basket Charles you punched him in
the nards yeah Nana fought nasty now if
you don't mind I'd like those tickets I
didn't hear no Bell
Jake I think those tickets are my
strawberry basket
guys stop it's a movie about cupcakes
you don't understand you don't have kids
a little chubby I'm fine I'm fine
Terry you just pulled two doubles you
must be tired
I'll stay for this Whitman debacle you
go home I'm not tired why would you
think I was tired
[Music]